[Musique]
bonsoir les enfants ponge ouvre alors
qu'avez-vous fait aujourd'hui ils ont le
tort pas trop haha
pourtant mon petit doigt me dit que
quelqu'un a fait un caprice ce mois
patron mais c'est le dernier je ne ferai
plus jamais la police
et pourquoi north parce que j'ai pas
longtemps et lorsqu'on a mal aux dents
on ne fait plus de caprice
j'ai mal aux dons parce que j'ai le dent
de sagesse qui pousse patron le
promeneur
alors qui va devenir sage bravo ne nous
défend le tir avec petit jabli ont des
chars ont bon voisin et même un beau
soir
qu'est-ce que tu amènes nous c'est vrai
enfin tête
j'ai eu mal ou ton très mal ou ton
pauvre que tu ne m'as
tu veux jouer avec nous cette frange
littorale des doors je ne peux pas jouer
je ne peux plus jouer du tout j'ai une
dent de sagesse qui pousse barrette
alors voyons ni color sait pas donc tu
peux plus jouer avec adam sagesse mais
voyons les enfants nous ferons des tas
de choses beaucoup plus intéressantes
par exemple nous étudierons 1
tu crois mais oui nous étudierons des
langues étrangères
c'est quoi ça ce sont les langues qu'on
parle dans d'autres pays
en france on parle à cette façon en
espagne on parle assez
non nicolas on parle espagnol et en
connaît déjà des langues étrangères
je fais en approche je connais le
chinois sha la la tv dvd à la ati vie
divine n'est pas du chinois du dollar
c'est du grec mais pas pendant que vous
étudiez les langues étrangères
moi je cherchais ce qu'il faut pour
soigner la dame sagesse a maintenant six
leçons good morning mr nicolas olala au
12 août
oh non non non goodnight liste un
preneur à la voix la mesta fonelle
qu'est ce que ça veut dire dit ne nous
ça veut dire bonne nuit mademoiselle pas
pr neil c'est facile
bien qu'aucun horse paix à oslo
je veux pas qu'on m'enlève ma dent de
sagesse puisque je lui je l'attends
[Musique]
approté langue étrangère va miss torn
ours
on va se coucher au bon mais je prenais
coup de maître nicole la voulez pas je
suis confiant mais non non non quand tu
aimes bien nous mêmes avec tes dents de
sagesse la jettent la lumière venue d'un
of good boy le zoo faut alors en ours
ça va mieux j'ai toujours mal patron et
puis elle me wrong to triste ce temps de
sagesse allons vite nous reposer nous
aussi demain ça ira mieux
ma nuit les petits faites de beaux rêves
[Musique]